okay so we've been following along the
series you've heard me talk about cloud
dlp and
all the ways that you can help you
inspect your data and de-identify it
with a whole bunch of different
techniques
we talked about the concepts and we saw
some code but
if you're wondering what dlp looks like
from a pointy clicky perspective
stick around for this extended episode
where i'll show you some dlp
functionality from the google cloud
console
[Music]
[Applause]
so for this demonstration we're going to
do a few things what we have
is a gcs bucket with a few files i'm
going to show you how to create an
inspect template
and then kick off an inspection job
that's going to tell us which files
might have some sensitive information in
them
then after that i'll show you how to
create a de-identification template
and then use that to create an identical
data set in bigquery with encryption
applied to some sensitive fields
okay so before we start let me just show
you real quick what we're working with
so
i have a gcs bucket some
data and in that bucket we just got some
text files csv files some of them have
sensitive values
some of them don't like for example
we have sample s10 has
some phone numbers while s20
has
names and social security numbers
so it's a mixed bag we got full names we
have social security numbers we've got
phone numbers so what we're gonna start
with is a
dlp inspection template
let's get rid of this guy
[Music]
so creating a template here is pretty
simple you go to the data loss
prevention page
create template and here you'll choose
either
an inspect template or the identify
template we'll go for inspect for now
okay let's call it our bucket inspect
templates
uh bucket
all right hit continue and now here's
the part where we choose what
info types we actually want to inspect
for so
i'm gonna go for since we saw that we
saw social security numbers
and let's add phone number
boom added done and then here we choose
the confidence threshold or likelihood
so it can go again from very unlikely to
very likely we'll just hit possible
right in the middle
hit create give that a second
all right so here's our inspection
template and here are the two info types
that we're looking for
the likelihood right there so now that
we have that template we can go over
here
back to the ddos prevention page we can
now create a
job or a job trigger
all right and so the cool thing about
dlp is that you can make it
inspect on a on a schedule so we'll call
this
our weekly inspection
and what we're going to inspect it's
going to be google cloud storage
and you can see that you can also do
bigquery or cloud data store
[Music]
all right and what was our bucket name
uh sample data
dlp okay
all right and here let me scroll down a
little bit you can actually choose to
use sampling so we're not going to use
sampling for this example but if you had
a very large data set
you might want to use sampling because
the more files that it scans for
the longer that job is going to take and
the more resources it's going to take up
so and then when you do choose to use
sampling you can always
adjust it here whether you want to
sample 50 or
20 or 100 which wouldn't make sense but
100
but for our purposes we're going to say
no sampling
here you can also choose the files that
you want to limit your
inspection to we'll just leave it at all
for now and hit continue
and now we choose our template we only
have one template so it's going to auto
populate our list of the templates that
we have
there it is our bucket inspect and here
are the details
again here our two info types and the
likelihood of possible so
for each job aside from just a template
you can also
add some info types here but again the
more
info types you look for the longer that
job is going to take so what i'm going
to do is just
deselect any additional info types so we
have nothing
we'll leave the likelihood again as
possible
hit continue and now here are the
actions that you want your job to take
after it's done so we're going to click
here save the bigquery and i'll show you
why that's important in a second
but all right our project a dlp
demo our data set is
bucket inspects so i created these data
sets ahead of time in bigquery
so before you do this you want to do
that yourself create your own
uh data set and then also an empty table
inspect and there are other actions that
you can add to each job like
publish to pub sub or notify by email
but for now we'll just go to bigquery
hit continue
and here you can choose when you want it
to to run so
you'll run daily weekly or custom so
we'll keep it
at weekly hit continue then it's gonna
give us
a recap of our job configuration in the
json object scroll down
past that we're gonna hit create
we're gonna confirm so now it's creating
that trigger
since it's a weekly one it's not running
yet so we just hit here run now
boom and they're running trigger weekly
inspection
so an inspection job could take some
time and that depends basically on how
big your data set is or how many info
types you specified
in that template all right so if you
want to see
how that job went you want to go back to
the data loss prevention page and under
inspect jobs
there it is click that and this is
pretty much a recap page of how the job
went so you'll see that it found 52
findings
52 findings were found in your data and
44 of them were phone numbers and eight
of them were social security numbers so
it's not much more information on this
page than that
if you want more information about each
of the findings that it made
you want to see what it threw out into
bigquery
so these are all the fields
associated with each finding that it
made in your data so i'll show you a
quick query we're going to select
the file name which should be here
relative path
and we want to include what else
info type and likelihood hit run
and there you go so it's not just the
file
has sensitive values values in it and it
made an entry in a database
it actually made an entry for each
finding that it made so
for example you'll see that sample s08
is here a few times because it has
a few phone numbers and you have the
option of including the actual value of
that data
but i didn't enable that for this uh
example
but you can see how how much
sensitive data a file might have rather
than just whether or not it does have
that sensitive information in it an
inspection job is a great way to find
out if your data might have any
sensitive value in it
now let's create a de-identification
template and see what we can do with
that
okay so before we create a
de-identification template
just want to show you something real
quick since we're going to use
tokenization
uh to de-identify information
under cryptographic keys i'll show you
that i've created a key ring that i
named
dlp keyring and a key that i named dlp
key and we're going to use that in a
second so
let's jump back to data loss prevention
once again we're going to go up here
create template this time instead of
inspect the identify
we'll call this bucket d id and this is
our bucket
the identification template
great uh continue and here we'll pick a
transformation rule and there are some
familiar faces in here we see redaction
replacement replace of info type down
here are our three tokenization
methods uh we're going to choose
cryptographic deterministic token
down here we're going to paste in that
key information the resource name
as a path and here it's going to want a
wrap key so it's pretty much going to
want a key that's been encrypted
by that encryption key i'll show you how
i generate that
real quick down here open up our cloud
shell terminal
and we're gonna set this variable to
open ssl random
base64 16 characters
boom and then here's what that looks
like right
so we're going to take that
take off any spaces
and we're going to pipe that into gcloud
kms encrypt
and then we're going to give it our key
ring and our key information so location
was global keyring
was dlp key ring
right uh our key
dlp key and we're going to specify
plain text file which is actually going
to be the
the value that we piped into this
command and then we're going to specify
a ciphertext file which is the output
that we wanted to go to so
ciphertext right hit enter
and what we got now is a file
that has some ciphertext so we can't
paste that in here so let's encode it to
base64. come on let's clear that up
[Music]
base64. no wrapping
and cipher text all right so let's take
this guy carefully select it
put it on a clipboard paste it over here
and boom there it is
all right so let's get rid of this
and continue on with the template so
with surrogate info type this is
again this is the value that's going to
prepend in front
of the encryption encrypted values
so since we're only going to look for
social security numbers i'll just make
it ssn
and we're going to specify the info type
down here
manage info types okay there it is us
social security number
and again you can choose up to 150 but
for now
social security number is fine and we'll
hit
create so the cool thing about the did
templates you can go over here to test
it out to make sure
everything's cool everything's working
so social security number is three
digits
two digits and four digits and
that is an example of what it's going to
look like when it's transformed
and there's our surrogate value right
here so to demonstrate
the identification in action what i'm
going to do is create a data flow job
which is going to take our csv files
from our bucket and then make
uh the identified version of that same
data in bigquery
so to create a data flow job let's head
over here to the navigation menu
scroll down data flow
create job from template so
job name let's just call it buckets the
identification
pid for short and under data flow
template we're going to choose data
masking
tokenization from cloud storage to
bigquery using cloud dlp
and now we want to specify that bucket
that i showed you earlier
it was sample data dlp
and we want to target the csv files that
are in there
so i don't know if you noticed before
but there was a data set
in bigquery that was called bucket did
totally empty no tables or anything this
will create the tables for it for us
and our project id dlp
demo
and the template name which is on my
clipboard
temporary location it's going to be in
the same bucket
slash temp great
all right let's look this over so now
what's happening is that dataflow is
going through all
all those csv files in our bucket and
then creating uh
an identical data set in bigquery with
those values
de-identified using tokenization so once
the data flow is done doing its thing
here's what it's going to look like in
bigquery so here's our data set
look at the id and now in that data set
there's a
table for each csv file that was in that
bucket
that i showed you earlier so if you
remember before we looked at sample
s20 that had a bunch of names social
security numbers let's query that table
and see what we get
[Music]
and boom there it is just like before
we've got name social security number
and some other data
but now the social security numbers are
completely unrecognizable because
they've been encrypted
the key that we specified in the
de-identification template
so now this data is essentially safe to
use for any analytic workflows that
might exist
in your organization and that's it that
was just a quick taste of what cloud dlp
is capable of doing
but if you have your own stories of how
cloud vlp has helped you secure your
data
feel free to share that in the comments
below thanks for watching
until next time